hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
a high-definition video review of an
ikea do high performance microphone
system portable microphone called the
HDR 7 so what you're looking at here is
unit itself it's a handheld microphone
with dual condenser mics an LCD screen
on the front and a tripod mount on the
bottom and it's really something that
you're going to see reporters bringing
around you're going to see people mount
it when they're not going to use the
built-in microphone on their camera the
mount this somewhere off screen in front
of them to record their audio with this
and feed that into their camera so this
is really a semi-professional sort of
video recording or sorry audio recording
device that you'll see a lot of
youtubers start to use and you'll see a
lot of video producers begin to use the
cardioid patterns on these microphones
as I can tell you from experience make
this sound very very accurate on the
left hand side you have an input gain
control and you also have some other
switches for turning it on and giving an
AC power when you're running out of
battery at the bottom you have that
tripod mount and your SD card slot and
it does come with a 1 gig card on the
other side you can see your USB input
your USB 2 PC connection and it comes
with the cable input high and low gain
and your output level control and that
brings us to the front of the device
which has a really professional clean
layout with the LCD screen in the middle
and you have your menu button to the
left of that underneath you have your
stop play pause and record buttons then
you have your little click wheel here
which is actually doesn't click down you
have an OK button next to it but that
little jog wheels to turn left to turn
right or to change your input to
actually turn up and down volume of what
you're recording is all done via that
wheel so that's a really nice clean
professional interface and speaking of
interface actually turning it on the
power button on the left hand side will
give you a good idea of the pretty fast
startup time and I'll get right into the
ability to record and basically once
this loads up here you'll be able to
basically just hit record and go and
when you stop and you go ahead and bring
it to your computer and listen to it if
it sounds a little bit quiet you can
turn up input gain but I'll tell you
right now this thing is a beast you can
be standing 15 feet away from it and if
you turn input gain all the way up it'll
stand like it'll sound like I'm sitting
right next to you talking into your ear
so I definitely recommend this for
people who are recording things that are
far away or want a solution to the
microphone on top
a camera that simply doesn't pick up
their voice well enough say you get the
rode videomic for your camera and you
point it out yourself and it's still too
quiet I'll recommend this and you'll be
able to put that perky far away out of
sight from camera view and still get
very crisp clean audio from the HDR 7 so
there's no doubt that the thing is a
top-notch hardware you're gonna be able
to easily take recordings and it's
actually really simple and easy to use
if you've ever seen those things at
interviews where they hold up to the the
person's mouth to talk it'll be
something like this and the HDR 7 is
really a great solution for the built-in
video mic on your camera I recently
purchased the Canon t2i and this is
actually one of the last videos you will
see that is not filmed with the Canon
t2i possibly the last so this is a
definitely a solution I'm going to be
utilizing to replace the canons built-in
video mic with the testing that I've
gone on with this I have to give this
product a 9 out of 10 for just a
phenomenal recording structure just the
wav format it records to the
customization of the interface and the
really powerful microphone I'll make it
just a great product the only negatives
that I can find were that the battery
life was somewhat disappointing and that
the shutdown time and delete time of
certain files for some reason took a
little bit longer than normal but
otherwise this is going to be excellent
for the beginning user and definitely
suggested and recommended by mkbhd and
if I could give it an editor's choice if
I was actually an editor of a website
well I definitely would so in the end
there's been mkbhd with an HDR 7 review
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace